hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen bei german das hier ist eine
kurze video ankündigung das ist lastet
short in nahrungsmittel vierte cd video
in englisch just go for the end of the
video also wir nehmen das video auf
deutsch und auf englisch auf weil wir
gerade keine zeit haben und hatte ihr zu
machen
diesen monat haben wir zwei große
jubiläen bei isar germany und zwar haben
wir einmal 100.000 abonnenten bekommen
hunderttausend und gleichzeitig
produzieren wir jetzt die zweihundertste
folge von in the german 200 folgen im
zwölf jahren dass das einfach wahnsinnig
viel und das möchten wir mit euch feiern
und aus diesem anlass möchten wir euch
einladen teil von unserem 210 video zu
werden was könnt ihr tun
ihr nehmt euch ein smartphone ihr geht
raus auf die straße so wie ich jetzt
hier zeigt uns eure umgebung und stellt
euch selber vor
wie heißt ihr seid ihr wo kommt ihr her
und warum guckt wie residieren wenn ihr
lust habt könnt ihr uns auch ein oder
zwei fragen stellen und die besten
videos die werden wir dann in einer
compilation in der 210 folge zeigen und
dann auch einige eurer fragen
beantworten also schickt uns unbedingt
euer video wie könnt ihr ihn verschicken
am besten könnt ihr das beim transfer
oder google drive hochladen und uns den
link per e mail schicken an info at the
german dot org
wir freuen uns auf eure videos bitte
machtmittel möchten möglichst viele
leute aus aller welt in diesem video
zusammenbringen
der english version office sowie
celebrating dass man projekte handelt
bauten subscribers und die silage stage
is crazy in den ruin hefte to handle the
video star
firmenservern des streetworkers way you
are what they want a whale watching the
german way in germany die trefferquote
für like the best videos of them out in
kombination mit videos von oliver
deshalb ließ centers your video video
und rich and google drive center feiert
bei e mail info at the german doctors
diary of supplies video modulbauer apple
denken wir freuen uns sehr auf eure
beiträge bitte schickt uns eure videos
und wir sehen uns schon ganz bald in
diesem video in zwei wochen ist es zwei
drei wochen
los geht's